I want to do this next story today, because
it's important to do.
But I want to be careful about the message
that I send to you.
And I have something that I'm going to admit
to you, which is that Donald Trump's mishandling
of Corona virus has pushed me to be as close
to a prepper as I as as I have ever been.
Now, preppers are those who believe that there
is a catastrophic disaster or emergency that
is likely to occur in the future.
And they make active preparations for it.
Typically, they stockpile food.
Sometimes they stockpile weapons and ammunition.
They stockpile elements of medical.
As you may have come to know them and a whole
bunch of other supplies.
And there's a political bent to prepping.
So you've got just general people who in general
preparedness advocates who often are not super
politically entwined with the movement.
But very often preppers are small government
conservatives.
They're prepping because they have a fundamental
distrust of government.
Sometimes they even have conspiracy theories
about government that lead them to prep.
Sometimes you have religiously motivated prepping.
Mormons, for example, often do long term food
storage as a part of their religion.
Now, I am not literally becoming a prepper.
I'm not buying guns, for example.
I'm not buying a year of food or anything
like that.
But there is no doubt that the degree to which
Donald Trump has been completely untrustworthy
and dishonest and incompetent day in and day
out when it comes to the Corona virus, a pandemic
has proven to me not that I need to have a
fundamental distrust of government and therefore
I should be prepping, but that the country
is dumb enough to elect people this poorly
suited to manage a crisis.
And I do need to be more prepared.
It's healthy to have a skepticism of government's
ability to solve every problem.
And I've never trusted government in certain
areas.
So, for example, I've never trusted government
to do foreign policy correctly.
Right.
Democrats and Republicans, we have hundreds
of years of history to vindicate us on that.
Look at the Middle East, look at Latin America,
look at so many of these other things.
That was always an area where I was very skeptical
of government.
Part of it is the people that we elect to
lead us.
I've never really trusted government to do
criminal justice correctly.
Look at the war on drugs.
Look at mass incarceration.
Look at cannabis.
Look all these different things.
But I have mostly believed that in a time
of real crisis, like a pandemic, I consider
the corona virus pandemic to be one of those
instances.
I mostly believe that the government would
pull it together and cross party lines and
put ignorance and politics and partisanship
aside and just take care of things.
And yet, as sixty thousand Americans have
died, 61000 really as we continue to find
fifteen twenty twenty five thousand new cases
of the virus every single day, as we clearly
are not yet doing nearly enough testing.
Donald Trump has failed.
He's failed to be proactive.
Every day he is going out and gaslighting
as thousands of people were dying on Monday.
Trump was publicly bragging about how great
everything he's done is on Tuesday as thousands
of people were continuing to die.
He went out and he did a complete propaganda
press conference using people with cognitive
disabilities as props to brag about how he
and a Vanska have saved the economy, as 30
million people now have lost their jobs.
Tens of thousands of businesses have been
unable to get money from that TPP program
because huge corporations took a ton of cash
and the money ran out.
So then I start to go to a dark place.
Our testing rate is forty first in the world
and Trump is bragging.
We've done the most tests.
We have the best tests.
It's total gaslighting and they can't be trusted.
So how does this get me to prepping while
I was thinking yesterday?
Imagine that we weren't dealing with a viral
pandemic for a second.
Imagine that the crisis was a bad actor, had
poisoned the water supply in urban areas and
the water was killing people.
Someone poisons the water supply.
People start to die.
We figure out what it is.
The water supply has been poisoned.
Okay?
People can't drink tap water anymore.
Get sorted out, but people need water to live.
Trump is the type of guy who would have a
slow response but would insist everything
is fine.
He'd say, just run the tap, we're gonna run
the taps and everything's gonna be fine.
It'll clear out as people start to die not
only from drinking tainted water, but also
dying of thirst.
He would go on TV and he would say the National
Guard has distributed tens of millions of
gallons more than any government has ever
done.
Who even heard of distributing 10 million
gallons before?
And people would be dying because 10 million
gallons of water is nothing in a country of
300 million and 10 days would go by and there
would still be too little water, much like
there are still too few tests.
And Trump would go on TV and say, hey, here's
10 CEOs who have developed great water filtration
devices.
We've given them a ton of cash.
Of course, huge cash cow for them.
They're making money.
And we're going to roll out a hundred thousand
water filtration kits to communities and we're
winning and people would be dying of thirst.
And when the hundred thousand filtration kits
show up six weeks later, it's not enough.
Now, I am not someone who has distrusted government
to effectively take care of some of these
basics, because I never imagined we'd have
someone so dishonest and so immoral in the
Oval Office.
But unfortunately, enough Americans voted
for it in 2016.
And that's what we have.
So I admit I've been buying more medical supplies.
I've been buying a water filtration capability.
I bought some of those water storage bricks
waiting for them to arrive.
And I'll constantly keep, you know, fifteen
gallons of water for myself and another 15
gallons for my girlfriend.
I've bought more nonperishable food.
Some supplies of electricity was out for,
say, three days, everything from a waterproof
matches to who knows what.
I've sort of gone down down the rabbit hole.
So I'm sort of cautiously not for the reasons
that the right wingers who are preppers do
it, but cautiously acquiring stuff, because
I never imagined the voters would do something
like put a Donald Trump in charge.
Am I crazy if anybody else is feeling this
way?
Let me know.
And I know that there will be right wingers
who say, David, you've taken the red pill.
You are now one of us.
No, no, no.
My my reasons for doing this are not small
government conservatism or sovereign citizen
ideology or any of that stuff.
It's wow.
The American people might elect a moron like
this again.
And he could or she could once again fail
us.
That's why I'm doing it.
Let me know your reaction.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.